here's Joe Biden claiming that Democrats
don't question election results
this is a nation that believes in the
role of law
we do not repudiate it
this is a nation that respects free and
fair elections we honor the will of the
people we do not deny it
we do not deny it
unless of course two weeks out from a
pivotal midterm election we get the
sense based on polling that we're about
to be spanked like the bad little girls
we are at which point we start making
excuses and planting the seeds for more
election denial just as we did after
Donald Trump won
that's exactly what's going on now even
as they try to destroy the careers
and tear down the character of people
who ask honest questions about the last
election and that would include Ron
Johnson who is the senator from
Wisconsin the Republican
one of the very few Republicans in the
entire U.S Senate who has actually
improved every year that he served there
that's the opposite of the normal
progression for republicans in the
senate in case you haven't noticed now
Ron Johnson is running against someone
who's legitimately far out his name is
Mandela Barnes on Twitter Barnes once
rang in the New Year by praising and few
politicians do this by praising Iran's
Ayatollah because he supports BLM and
we're quoting the first tweet of 2015
from at Khamenei IR is black lives
matter let that sink in
may this be a most wonderful year for
you and yours Barnes wrote
so he's got the Ayatollah vote Barnes
also wants to abolish ice defund the
police and end cash bail so that would
result in further chaos in the total
Destruction of American society it might
be worth following up on that but no the
media in Wisconsin are still talking
about Ron Johnson's election denial
here's his hometown newspaper which no
one reads In fairness attacking him the
other day for it quote election deceiver
science fabulous billionaire benefactor
after 12 years is time to turn limit
Senator Ron Johnson
so again just to be clear
Democrats are sending people to prison
for questioning the last election trying
to prevent people from getting elected
in the midterm election for questioning
the last election while at the very same
time telling you that the 2016 election
was rigged the midterm will likely be
rigged and we know for a fact the 2024
election is not on the level
how does this work exactly
Senator Ron Johnson joins us tonight
Senator thanks so much for coming on
um it's is it a little weird to be
attacked by your hometown newspapers and
election denier on the very same day the
people who run the Democratic party are
preemptively denying the outcome of an
election that hasn't even happened yet
well hello Tucker those are some of the
better headlines I received from the
mainstream media here in in Wisconsin
yeah let's face it what is happening
here is a classic tactic of the left
falsely accused your political opponents
of doing exactly what you do uh let's
face it how many leading Democrats uh
said that the 2016 election was
legitimate no they spent four years
trying to overturn it a corrupt FBI
investigation and it was the complicit
and corrupt media that allowed all this
to go on they were fed all the false
information you know why why have they
uh exposed the people that fed them
false information what about the 570
riots during the summer of 2020 2000 Law
Enforcement Officers injured one to two
billion dollars worth property damage
couple couple dozen people killed
including two people here in Kenosha you
know why don't they talk about that no
all they do is focus on January 6th I
think this has always been a massive
diversionary operation against their or
from their own wrongdoing so again
classic classic uh operation of the left
it's a classic tactic and unfortunately
they have the complicit and corrupt
media that's backing them up
so you're saying things out loud you're
not supposed to say aloud we interviewed
earlier today Dr Robert Epstein who is
um a professor of psychology who studies
Google and he told us that he has never
seen Google put its sizeable thumb on
the scale more aggressively than in
Wisconsin right now that Google is
trying to lose you the race and get
Mandela Barnes elected because they're
so threatened by the things that you are
saying are you aware of this and what's
your response to it
no I'm fully aware and I know of his
work you know he's talking about how
Google uses their search to manipulate
opinion uh how they only text for
example get out the vote to Democrat
supporters we saw Mark Zucker Zuckerberg
use his Zucker bucks uh completely took
over the Green Bay election in 2020 and
yet this is the safest most secure
election of course it wasn't there are
all kinds of irregularities I held a
hearing in December of 2020 because I
was not going to scornfully dismiss the
legitimate concerns of tens of millions
of Americans because observers weren't
able to observe here in Wisconsin there
were we had a legislative audit Bureau
nonpartisan bipartisan
audit of our election 31 recommendations
because things went wrong we had our
Wisconsin election commission issued
guidances contrary to state law election
clerks procedures contrary to state law
and yet we're all supposed to say oh no
it's the most secure election it wasn't
no it wasn't and they absolutely hate
you for saying that out loud and that's
why we're certainly rooting for you
Senator Ron Johnson of Wisconsin good
luck in that race
have a good night
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight